this episode is made possible by Wix get
25% off your premium plan by following
the link below
time travel is one of the most common
and confusing tropes in modern media the
premise is simple someone in their
current time uses some device or the
laws of physics to travel through time
either backwards or forward depending on
the subject matter it's incredibly
popular as seen by the sheer number of
films and TV shows based on the idea but
if the ability to travel through time is
simply dependent on the invention or
discovery of some new technology
why haven't people from the future come
back in time to visit us in 2009 Stephen
Hawking decided to put the possibility
of time travel to the test he hosted a
fancy party complete with champagne hors
d'oeuvres balloons and a big banner that
said welcome time travelers to make sure
that only real time travelers could
attend the party Hawking only released
the invitations after the event was over
the card read you are cordially invited
to a reception for time travelers and
listed the date address coordinates and
of course the courtesy no RSVP required
Hawking said I'm hoping copies of it in
one form or another will survive many
thousands of years maybe one day someone
living in the future will find the
information and use a wormhole time
machine to come back to my party proving
that time travel will one day be
possible as he expected no one showed up
offering at least some evidence that
time travel to the past might not be
possible of course like any good
scientist Hawking readily admitted that
this one experiment doesn't absolutely
disprove the idea of time travel as it
could certainly be possible that the
people of the future simply didn't know
about his party but assuming time travel
is possible and assuming future time
travelers did know about Hawking's party
why might they have declined to show up
if we've learned anything from the
movies it's that time travel often has
unforeseen and dangerous consequences
it's not unreasonable to think that if
we ever were to discover a reliable
method of traveling through time it
would be heavily regulated and time
travelers would have to be thoroughly
vetted monitored and trained let's
assume that in the year thirty eighteen
the people of the future establish a
time force a highly trained and
secretive group that specializes in
safely traveling through time what
considerations might they have for
sending someone back to a past event
like Hawking's party the assumed rule
number one would be don't mess with your
past self or relative
as evidenced by films like Back to the
Future things can get a little
convoluted when you interfere with your
own past self or your past relatives in
Back to the Future we see a modified
example of what's called the grandfather
paradox the idea that if you go back in
time and kill your grandfather before he
met your grandmother you would never be
born meaning you wouldn't have existed
to go back in time and kill him in the
first place thus creating a paradox in
Back to the Future Marty accidentally
finds himself in his father's place and
has to work to undo his mistake and get
his parents to fall in love to save his
own existence hypothetically this would
be fairly easy to avoid just make sure
you know where past you or your
ancestors were before you travel to that
time period and avoid them another
concern often referenced in film and TV
is the butterfly effect the idea that
the simplest action can ripple through
time and create dramatic and unforeseen
changes the 2004 film of the same name
explores this idea in an interesting way
the protagonist finds he has the ability
to send his adult mind back in time to
inhabit his younger selfs body and
attempts to avoid traumatic events in
his past while unwittingly changing his
or his friends future for the worse in
the case of more traditional time-travel
where someone steps into a time machine
and appears somewhere in the past in the
same physical body the concern would be
more general rather than specific to
that person and his or her contacts the
idea that any small action such as
bumping into someone on a train could
cause horrible consequences and throw
the course of the future out of whack is
pretty common and while technically it
could be the case no one seems to think
the actions they take today can change
the world in any meaningful way perhaps
that's one reason no one showed up to
Hawking's party because tiny actions do
drastically change future events and
they didn't want to risk their own
existence if that is the case then we
can at least take heart in the fact that
our actions are significant and that we
can make a difference in the world
there's your motivation for the day
another possibility is that time travel
is possible in the future but only
forward in time this seems to be the
most likely as technically we already
know it to be possible in the film
interstellar we see the protagonist
leave earth while his children are still
young
later on he receives a video message
from them but they're both adults this
is a dramatized version of what we see
when astronauts leave the earth today
due to the nature of gravity if an
astronaut had an identical twin back on
earth when he returned from matters
basse he would be very slightly younger
than his twin there are some areas of
space where time acts quite differently
than elsewhere such as in the vicinity
of black holes if some brave astronaut
wanted to travel to the future he could
orbit a black hole and time would slow
down for those aboard the ship but time
would continue at its normal rate on
earth effectively allowing the ship's
crew to move forward more quickly
through time this difference is called
time dilation and it's a fascinating
subject
the only problem for those brave time
travelers of the future is that as far
as we know there's no reversing this
effect if you'd like to see how it works
for yourself there's a time dilation
calculator in the description one final
reason that time travelers might not
have shown up for Hawking's party is the
possibility that while time travel may
be possible in the future we as a
species never make it that far the fact
that no one dropped by simply to say yep
you're right just keep working on those
formulas could indicate that there's no
one left in the future to receive
Hawking's invitation it's an ominous
thought and probably not the case but
it's not beyond the realm of possibility
the most likely scenario
assuming time travel to the past is even
possible is that time travelers would
strive to make themselves as boring and
unremarkable as possible avoiding
contact with people of the past and
simply observing for a while before
returning to the future who knows maybe
there have always been time travelers in
our society and we've just never noticed
them that being said if you're not a
secret time traveler and you do want to
be noticed what better way to do it then
with a sleek new website from Wix Wix
can handle any project you throw at it
whether you want to host videos share
your photo gallery book clients sell
products or just about anything else you
could ever want
whether you need a professional website
for your own personal use or for
e-commerce music hotels or restaurants
Wix does all the heavy lifting like
hosting custom domains email marketing
and more allowing you to focus on the
creative side of things you have total
creative freedom over your websites
allowing for limitless possibilities and
you don't even have to be a web designer
Wix caters to everyone regardless of
skill level whether you're a novice
business owner or seasoned website
builder as a special thank you for
watching second thought the first 30
users to build a site using the link
below can get 25% off a premium plan by
using the coupon code second underscore
thought to support the channel and start
building your own professional website
visit Wix using the link below
if you enjoyed this video consider
subscribing and clicking the little bell
to stay up to date on the latest videos
if you're not sure what to watch next
check out these playlists full of other
great content as always thanks for
watching and supporting second thought
and we'll see you next week